All right, if I could have your attention, please
we're going to go and get started. We've got pockets of people that are just
continuing to talk right here right here.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah, get on them who said get on them.
So we are in week seven
and what you'll notice is in
the next few weeks now next week. We're not
going to be here because of fall break so next week
you get the week off, but then we'll get
started. We'll come back and we'll just have a five five sessions
left. But what
you'll notice is as we get closer to the final
few weeks our instructions going to become more
and more specific to what will I actually
do at a micro group and we've been
studying processes and systems
and Concepts and
precepts and now it's going
to turn a little bit more into the Practical and
so but that doesn't
mean we don't review and so we're gonna go ahead and review this is our this
apple making pathway. Everyone is
expected to come to worship. Let me see if I can get this
thing we'll started here.
Yes, I can everyone is expected to
come to worship but we don't believe it's enough just
to come to worship and sit together and and there's
always going to be good music and always going to be good preaching but
but the requires an exchange of an idea
and so we we come into
relationship and our community groups and our
community groups are where relationships are built. They're open
groups. They're ongoing groups. They
don't have a start date and an end date
and so they're not like some of our equipping or training meetings,
but but they're
also some of them are large we had 50
in one of our community groups on Sunday, which is the biggest
group I've seen since I've been here but some of
them are large and and all of them except a
couple of ladies groups are
A co-ed groups men and
women in the same group. So what we're asking you to do is to get
involved in what we're calling a micro group and this is
The Sweet Spot. This is where we believe that
transformation is most likely to happen. And why
is that
Well, first of all, let's discuss I'm talk about transformation. What
is a disciple one who's following Jesus one
who's being changed by Jesus and one is
committed to the mission of Jesus and that's disciple making so
how many of you got that memorized.
Okay, looky here. We've got four or
five. You know, what I'm gonna do next. I'm gonna call on you.
Have you stand up? No, I didn't ask you for permission.
But I would love you would encourage me by coming
up to me and say Hey listen to this and then just telling me and I'll be
fired up. So we've talked about this that
the reason we are calling this our sweet
spot is that we believe that Jesus style
disciple making happens best in the
context of a relationship and very
little relationships are built in a large group
setting because you're sitting facing the same
direction listening to one person speak, but the
closer we get see Community groups, you can begin to see these
relationships form because you do have that give and
take opportunity for a conversation but in
the micro groups, this is what we're beginning to experience and
just last week because now I'm a little
I'm a little more familiar to you one of our sweet disciple
making young ladies came.
Says, you know, we can't read a word that you're writing.
And I'm trying to decide who it was. I'm gonna
take my time. All right conversations. Oh crud
conversations con.
ver
say misspelled. I know you're gonna complain about that
too. All right, we'll have opportunities for conversation,
but we'll also have opportunities because of our conversations to
build relationships relationships.
It's starting to go bad on me again here and
we want to we want transparency
now, why is transparency important?
Cool looking good, doesn't
it? Alright guys, I started this speed up. You can understand
but transparency is important because we do
as westerners have a an incredible
propensity to share just pieces of
ourself that we want getting out. It's it's like
social media. We don't post the pictures of ourselves just
out of bed without makeup on ladies or with our bed
head men. We don't post those pictures. We wait
until we look good and then we'll take several. You
don't just post the first picture you take it
and what do you do?
You look at it.
Let me just ask you a question. This is transparency. All right, when you
take a group picture, who's the first person you
look at when you look at the group picture?
Yourself, of course, and you can
tell if it's a good picture or not based upon what?
If you look good doesn't matter what the rest of group looks
like, right? So transparency means
okay, there may be parts of me that need
to to have the scrutiny of scripture and
the accountability of people whom I
trust to to help me with these issues. So
transparency is important and eventually I'm gonna go slow here.
intimacy
All right intimacy means that you're going
to be able to share things with me that you might not be able to share with
anyone else that I'll be able to trust you with those things because I
know that you love and care for me the way I love and care
for you and that's intimacy. All right, so there's a a quick
review and now we're
gonna get started on page four of your handout how to
make a disciples and a very important piece
of how to make disciples starts from the
very beginning choose disciples wisely. Now
what's going to happen when this 12 week
series is over is that we're going to be very close to
the holidays and I would suggest that during the
holidays you probably not start a group because the
holiday seasons crazy people are busy they're
going here and there but at the beginning of the first of
the year, that's when people are most likely to
make a commitment towards something important. And so what I
would suggest for you is as you were beginning
to put together a plan to make
Disciples you choose disciples wisely. What does
that mean? It's a crucial question because you
are going to be investing your life in
another person. It's going to take time. It's
going to take energy. It's going to take just a
kind of an emptying of self. Whereas
you'd rather sit by yourself and do what you like. Now, you're
going to be planning to eat with or sit with somebody and and
Converse and go down that
relational Road of intimacy and vulnerability and
transparency and accountability. And so some of
you are still deciding. I don't know
if I can do this. I really don't know if I can do this.
And and frankly, you just don't
know if you have it in you but I want you to hear me say
that I believe that God is preparing you each one of
you each disciple maker right now that never
before perhaps. Have you been confronted as
Abruptly as you're being confronted now
to do something for the Lord
in the area of disciple making but
but here I want you to hear me say this too and this is just as important
that God is also Preparing People to respond
to your invitation.
God has someone out there who needs an
intentional leader to come alongside them
and invite them to be a part of A discipleship
experience. So, how do I choose a person
to disciple? Well, the selection criteria is very important
and that's what we'll be talking about tonight is selection Criterion,
and I'm going to ask you not to look for the most. Holy person.
Okay.
If I find somebody really, holy then
my work here is done. Right? Well, I wasn't
your work now. Did you know that sometimes the
holiest people are not necessarily the
most receptive people?
They in their mind have already got it figured out and they
don't need to be transparent because frankly there's nothing to
be transparent about.
Right, sometimes the greatest
disciples are new to the faith.
I tell you a story that happened in This Very Room
about two weeks ago. Maybe three weeks ago a brand
new believer had just come to the
Lord and it just moved to the area and was looking for
someone to help them with their new faith. And so I
get word that this is going to happen. It's hard for
me to respond while I'm up here somebody walks in the back, but they
walk back. They talk to my Administrative Assistant. Yes, somebody's
calling.
I don't know who it is, but you don't get to talk to me right
now.
All righty.
but they
they come and their question was is I
just need somebody to help me study the
Bible.
And very very simple question. And so it just so
happened that I had eaten lunch with a cup and I
knew that the female in this couple was a
disciple maker and would love to have a
young new fresh faith in her
group. And so I intentionally took her
over to that group and they had a great first night and then
after that night, I didn't
ask her to do this, but I kind of knew that it was gonna happen. She brought
her to me. She said I want
you to meet my new best friend and what
what happened to her is that she'd gone
from an intentional leader to someone who was vibrantly awake
that got it entrusted to her someone who
was new in the faith.
It's like a brand new parent and brand new
parents. My kids are grown and gone. I've got grandbabies now,
but I remember when my first little girl was born and
I remember being a total fool for
this little girl and I was hoping for a boy
and back then you didn't know before you got one but man when God gave me
a girl it was like I've never been so
in love right? Well, that's
what happens to us when we're giving an opportunity when
God entrusts someone to us who is new in
the face and let me see if it's
got this got this right somebody who's new to the face and you're
thinking Lord. I am so honored that you would bring
them this direction. So you're you're deciding who to pick
you're not looking for the holiest person. You might
be looking for someone who's new to the faith. And what I
would like for you to do is do what Jesus did and this is how he chose
the 12. Okay. They were
not the best and brightest.
The disciples were not the best and brightest.
The best and brightest had already been snatched up
by other rabbis.
Okay, it's the truth when they you find a young man and you
believe he's got great potential for leadership and
especially for Learning and so they would
snatch them up and they would follow their Rabbi and the
fact that these men were working and they were doing what their
father had done and they're part of the family business now means that
they hadn't been picked. They've been overlooked and
discarded by the religious leaders at this point. They were
just common men. And so we're
gonna look at the jesus' example, we're gonna learn what Jesus did
in Luke 6:12 and 13. It
says in these days. He Jesus went
out to the mountain to pray.
All night he continued in prayer to God. Now.
This was not uncommon for Jesus Jesus set
the examples for us as far as how to pray
and and when to pray and why to pray
and then we get a hint as to what he was praying about.
And when they came what did he
do? He called his disciples and shows
from them 12 whom he
named Apostles. So the Bible doesn't explicitly
say this but it does imply that the reason Jesus
was praying is that he was about to go pick the
disciples and and that's exactly what he did. So
the first thing you do when choosing a
disciple is pray.
You ask God to show you those who are hungry
for more of him. If if
you don't hear me say anything else this I
believe is the number one Criterion.
Okay in your community group, do you know someone who?
Who seems to be seeking to know more of
him now? You can be a brand new believer.
And not be seeking to know more of him.
and you can be
you can be a superstar. I used to say an Awana
Award winner and then somebody from Moana really I
was offended so I don't say that anymore.
but a super Christian and still
not seeking and to know more of him, but you're seeking
to know hungry for someone the Bible
describes it as spiritual thirst or spiritual hunger, but
they're hungry for more of him
and number two. They're willing to clear space in
their schedule now.
I know your life.
I know that there was a day when
you were shocked how quickly
the microwave would heat up your food.
But I know now you're you're tapping on the on the window like
come on. Come on. Come on.
Right. It's a microwave. It's it's remarkable technology,
but it's just not fast enough, right?
So I also know I'm from
North Dallas and if you didn't know this Dallas traffic is legendary
for making people insane. And so
Edmond is done about a
hundred thousand people which is a lot.
hmm
I think it's enough to have a left turn lane. That's my opinion.
All right, and or an
on-ramp or something, but since we don't have those, let's
just be honest because we believe in transparency and
vulnerability. How many of you today complained about
traffic at least one time? Okay. Look see we're busy
that five seconds is gonna
cost me right but but we're
looking for someone who's willing to say, I want more of
him and I'm willing to enter into a relationship with you because together
you and I are going to be able to discover more of
him and I'm gonna do whatever that takes. Okay. And so
you're also looking for those who are Faithfully apply
what they're learning to their lives. So
there's a spiritual sensitivity. This is the first and
most important criteria and why because a disciple
is someone who is following Jesus and being changed
by Jesus. So they're gonna be need to be open to
transformation. So I'm gonna ask you
to do this. I'm gonna ask you to ask
To give you one person you say I thought it was a micro
group. Yes, it is, but I don't want you to
Start when you finally have four. All right,
just ask God for one person.
And when God gives you that person you to start
meeting together and You Begin pouring your life into
that person and you begin to sense what God is up
to?
And and you know what they're going to do. They're gonna say, you know,
I got a friend who would really really get
something out of this. Do you think you think you
might and if it's a brand new group you could say absolutely bring them
and you can start a new relationship that way and so
what's happening is immediately he's kind
of catching or she's kind of catching. The the
spirit of this is me committing to the mission of
Jesus disciple making so I bring my friend and
then he and I grow and Faith together and then maybe we'll
start a micro group outside of this one. So that's
what that's what you're doing is you're just asking for
one person. And when that when that when
God gives you that one person you get started.
And don't worry about the
number of people you disciple. I would love for you to have a micro
group a micro group can be two or three or
four. It just can't be five six seven eight or nine.
Okay, we'll talk about that in a minute. So you just instead
of concerning yourself about numbers instead
of concerning yourself about. What are you going to tell the
people that the
at this
at the community group or what? Are you going to see when you
see me? What are you gonna say? Don't worry about any of that worry about
your own faithfulness with those who God is entrusted
to you. Maybe your first your first time
maybe God interests to you one.
And remember our thing just to the right of the
micro group is the one-on-one experience. That's good too. Right? So
number two, you're going to you're going to pray for someone
who has is looking for Jesus more of
him.
Someone who has a spiritual interests. That
means that the spirit of God has already
at work in this person's life and they have a hunger for
Spiritual things. They may not know much but as
long as they're hungry to know more and they're going
for more of God's truth and they're quick
to respond. So start praying and start looking
around you.
um, it doesn't have to be somebody in your CG,
but it can be
In in our room, there's a young couple who when
covid came they decided to start doing discipling in
their neighborhood.
And he meets with the Earth some
of the men early before they go to work and she
meets with their wives in the afternoon when
all the kids are asleep.
And two weeks ago a couple
that they were discipling in their neighborhood started coming
to disciple making 101. So
you see the process of not just spiritual young adult
now being others centered, but
now these are not just disciple makers but they're bringing disciples whom
they have made that will one day be disciple makers
of themself what I told one of them was like Hey
That's grandparenting baby. I am proud of you and you
know, very young couple and they look at me like what what did you
say, but I think they know what I meant. So anyway, so number
three and this is a very unfortunate acronym.
Okay find somebody faithful
available and teachable. All right.
I told my wife we're looking for fat people.
And but it's faithful available and teachable.
So let's look at second Timothy 2:2.
This is Paul.
To his disciple Timothy his young Protege whom
he's pouring his life into and what
you have learned from me in the
presence of many witnesses entrust of
Faithful Men.
Who will also be able to teach others also,
so you're looking for someone who's faithful available
and teachable to choose faithful people hungry
for more of him with an interest in spiritual things.
People who are also available who will create time
in their busy schedule to meet.
None of us has time to do this.
Okay. Listen to me. None of us has time to
do this.
That means we just have to make time for what's important.
I don't know what that means for you. There may be something you have to stop doing.
It won't be many weeks from now. You'll hear me saying
if if you eat a lunch or breakfast and you
have time because you can meet somebody for lunch or breakfast
right? But so they're
gonna be available choose those who are teachable. You
don't believe they don't believe they've got everything figured out.
There's spiritually an actual intellectually curious to
learn and to change. So remember that
acronym now, we're gonna finish up with
this fight the temptation to repeat old patterns.
Now what that means is
this and and and I'm gonna run the risk of
making some of you angry right now
and I don't want to but I just have to tell you what the truth
is. Okay old patterns.
Are so ingrained and entrenched in us that
it is hard for us to see a new
model. All right, even when disciple making
is articulated as plainly as
you as I can you see it through the VIN the
lens or the grid of
the way things have always been and and
we love that. We we love
hearing a good Vision casting and we're
used to hearing speakers talk about the way the church
can become more but but we
still we see this new vision through old lenses. And
so basically what
we do is we talk about this new vision, and we
don't follow it up with any action.
and even less accountability
so old patterns can allow
committed Christians to struggle to
accept personal responsibility for
disciple meeting and making
And it's just simply never been a part of
their old pattern so they can't imagine doing something. They've never done before.
Okay many things that we
do at the church don't lead to changed lives doesn't mean
they're wrong. Okay, my very
first huge responsibility at this church
was a gourmet hot dog contest.
You and I had a great time and a bunch
of men responded and it was a lovely night, but I
frankly I don't know if anybody's live was changed that night. All
right, we had fun and it wasn't anything wrong with it, but
But we can do better than gourmet
hot dogs. All right, so and
I see my my pastor in the
back right here preaching plays an important part and
a huge role in community and communicating
the truth of God, but he's honest enough
to say but it's frustrating when people get up and walk out
of here unchanged and it happens every Sunday. Sometimes now some
are changed but most move on. Okay big
meetings and programs can be
encouraged and and inspiring but people will always
need a place to slow down and focus
on the deeper things in life and then be confronted
by someone who loves and trusts them to go further. That's
exactly why Jesus did what he did with his
disciples. So let's let's point
out a few things that old patterns look like we're
westerners old patterns usually look like
up into the right.
Okay. I've I've done this with some
of you guys.
They'll say man that we
started.
Seven weeks ago and he said man when that great.
And that and I said, yeah it was I said, we had 27 people.
Why I say that.
That's not success.
You know and it's because every time I've
ever had a conversation about church success, it's always been
evaluated by numbers.
Right, and that's what we used to say my last Church up into
the right as long as it's up into the right.
You know, that's that's an old pattern and
I'm saying you can't have more than five or
six in your group.
Because it's not a micro group anymore. And you start losing people
to The Fringe. It's like you want me to do this with just a few. No, Jesus
wants you to do this was just a few.
Right, it's not without what I want. So big meetings
are important, but they don't always result
in the kind of spiritual maturity. We
don't evaluate spiritual maturity by attendance or
even by retention of biblical knowledge.
Those are good things.
But transformation is the only real metrics for
discipleship old pattern
Church discipleship strategies revolve around Bible
study classes, and that's a good thing, but we're
not we're not going to be doing just Bible study.
We're going to be doing personal evaluation and
assessment and accountability together.
How many of your old enough to remember when Sunday night was called?
Church training
All right. Yeah, and we used to also
call it a church discipleship nine.
And it was basically just a time when we met together for
more Bible study. And again, I'm not against the Bible studies. I'm
not against anything that our church does necessarily. I'm just
saying that we can do this more intentionally.
And we can focus on transformation with people that
we love and trust and invest and poor lives
into and when we begin to see transformation, it
literally changes your world.
It rocks your world. So I
want to show you something that happened just
in the last four months, so I've been here four months.
And I told you the story about how it got started. This
is Keith, Skittle.
He's the first guy at my last church that said. Hey, I got questions.
He was raised in the east coast. He was a Catholic.
And so I let him buy
me some barbecue, by the way. I'll let you buy me barbecue, too. But anyway, I let
him buy me some barbecue and I said Keith.
What you need is to be discipled and he looks at me like oh
and so we met the very next week. And
before that
next week started this guy right here.
Where is he?
Is his rusty rusty comes to
me by way of a very unimp an
impersonal email from my pastor. It was
like John said, hey, I'm copying my friend the
disciple maker because it sounds like you need to be discipled. That's how that's
how good. I knew Rusty. So he and I were the first
ones to meet in the IHOP.
And I laid this Vision out to them and we begin to meet there's my
mom. Yeah, I'll pray for her. Okay. All right.
So we prayed for so we started me and
I said if we're still meeting together in two years. I've not
done my job.
That I would like for you guys to eventually lead your own
group.
And so this is July 14th. Okay.
I've been at Henderson Hills
now for a month and two weeks and they sent
this to me just to let them know. We're still going we're
still going.
And and then this morning I get this
one. This is October 5th.
And this is Rusty and this
is Rusty's new group.
And I know this guy and I know this guy and I know
this guy and I know this guy.
I don't know this guy.
Never met him.
You see how this works.
I didn't have to be there to say hey, this is a guy who might could use
a disciple now they're looking for themselves.
Now they're investing their lives and finally guys says, what
are you guys doing over here?
We'll come here and sit down with us and you can figure it out.
you know, and so
When I got this.
Who makes me emotional?
Picture this morning. I texted him this afternoon.
And I said would it be okay if
If I showed this picture tonight, and he
said absolutely then he sends me another
picture. He says we're all at the Raiders game. Anyway, so
the whole group went to the Rangers game this afternoon. So anyway, I
didn't get to go. But anyway,
So I just I'm trying to help you
understand that your micro
group is going to be a different experience than
anything you've ever done. I'm gonna ask you
to intentionally not fall back into Old patterns.
If you do then it's
always gonna be like, it's always been but
what we're wanting is what I believe Jesus style
disciple making promises and that
is is that there's going to be a higher interest
and spiritual things. There's going to be groups that
are hungry for more of Jesus and then because
there is an intentional leader. There's gonna be in people
included in ways that it's literally going
to change your life personally and
our church corporately.